see that strip of stars splashed across
the night sky that's our home galaxy the
Milky Way you can see it from Earth
because we live right on the outskirts
far away from all the fun stuff
happening at its center what would it be
like to reside in its galactic downtown
what what our night sky look like when
we get sucked into a black hole this is
what if and here's what would happen if
the earth was near the center of the
Milky Way the Milky Way is huge about
100,000 light years across it has four
large spiral arms encircling its center
that makes it a barred spiral galaxy
just like most galaxies in the
observable universe if the earth packed
up its belongings and moved to the heart
of the Milky Way things would be looking
pretty bleak for the survival of any
kind of life on the planet but not
because of the Milky Way's supermassive
black hole
the earth is located in a quiet
neighborhood in one of the smallest
Spurs of the Milky Way the Orion Arm
we've got approximately 27,000
light-years between us and the galactic
center it's a comfortable spot to live
in the temperatures on earth are just
right to sustain life and there aren't
too many space hazards that could wipe
out our existence
well I didn't say it's completely safe
today
living anywhere near the center of the
Milky Way would be different it would
depend on what part of that center the
earth had the misfortune to occupy the
closer you get to the heart of the
galaxy that tighter the stars are packed
together because of this high star
density the earth would be blasted with
a lot more radiation than what the Sun
throws at you right now under these
circumstances the odds of life ever
evolving would be pretty small but if
the earth moved to the center together
with all its inhabitants you'd find
yourself very unlucky Earth's
magnetosphere wouldn't be able to
protect you from space radiation
blasting from all directions this could
change the Earth's climate and cause
everything on the planet to either
mutate or die if you lived your biggest
concern would be a close encounter with
a supernova a supernova occurs when a
massive star collapses releasing radio
waves x-rays cosmic rays and gamma rays
into space for all we know one massive
stellar body could throw the earth out
of the sun's orbit our planet would be
surrounded by foreign stars until one of
them exploded in a supernova and wiped
us out for good but it would look
spectacular from Earth if only for a
brief moment there's another big hazard
that lies within the Milky Way's center
a supermassive black hole called
Sagittarius a star
if getting sucked into a black hole
isn't on your to-do list consider
yourself lucky the earth might stay far
enough from it that we wouldn't get
engulfed by this cosmic beast but we
could get close enough to get caught in
the black hole's orbit at a distance of
twenty billion kilometres from the black
hole's event horizon the earth could
develop a speed of 25 million kilometers
per hour
that's over 230 times faster than the
speed our planet is moving at right now
so would that mean strong winds more
natural disasters would you end up
flying off into space and bright into
the black hole it sure wouldn't be good
for you or anything else on the Earth's
surface the earth is perfectly designed
to be right where it is it can survive
on the outskirts of the galaxy but you
wouldn't want it to be anywhere else the
most dangerous place for a planet to be
located is anywhere near the center of a
galaxy any galaxy if you just want a
nice view your best bet might be to
teleport the earth to the middle of a
nebula instead but that's a story for
another what if
[Music]